c'est un combat à armes inégale que même
les pompiers en Gironde dans le
sud-ouest de la France le département
fait face à deux feux majeurs qui ont
déjà ravagé 6800 hectares de forêt et
forcer l'évacuation de plus de 10 000
résidents le feu tourne le feu
fonctionne un escargot à un moment le
fait est revenu sur lui-même le feu est
parti au sud le fait partie au nord le
feu nous a pris à nous étonner pour
faire face à ces incendies sans
précédent les pays d'Europe se sert les
coudes
Grecs qui vont arriver aujourd'hui on a
aussi des avions suédois et puis on a
aussi des moyens terrestres qui vont
être mobilisés d'Allemagne de Pologne
d'Autriche de Roumanie ce pompier
allemand fait partie des renforts
on est arrivé dès qu'on a pu afin
d'aider nos confrères
mais les autres pays européennes sont
pas en reste la Grèce le Monténégro la
Bulgarie le Portugal et l'Espagne
combattu aussi des feux de forêts
[Musique]
c'est tellement sec il n'a pas plu
depuis des semaines un nouveau plan
national d'adaptation au changement
climatique sera mis
en compte à la retraite
l'important sécheresse jumelée à la
vague de chaleur sans précédent qui
frappe de plein fouet l'Europe depuis le
début de l'été pourrait finalement
forcer les gouvernements à faire face à
l'urgence climatique ici